how do we find the area of this
inscribed Pentagon inside of this circle
here well we know it's a regular
pentagon and they're giving us the
radius as eight units but what we want
to do is we want to divide this up into
congruent triangles so let's do that
first let's put this regular pentagon up
into congruent triangles it has a radius
of eight but let's go ahead and see if
we can find out the area of one of these
triangles then we can multiply it by
five to find the total area of the
Pentagon so the first thing I want to do
is we want to find that central angle
and we know in a circle there's 360
degrees so if we divide that by five
since there's five of them that's going
to give us a central angle of 72 degrees
right but then if we drop an altitude
here which this is called the apothem
it's also the height of this triangle
here it's going to split that 72 degree
angle into 36 and 36 and we know that
the hypotenuse here is the radius okay
across from the right angle that's eight
but how do we find out this side length
and this side length well let's go ahead
and make this triangle a little bit
larger so we can see a so we have 36
degrees let's call this eight let's call
this a four apothem and let's call this
X for the side length so we're going to
use a little bit of trigonometry here
let's start off by doing the sine so the
sine of 36° equals the opposite side
over the hypotenuse so that's going to
equal x over eight if we multiply both
sides by eight that's going to give us X
here so let's see what that comes out to
it's eight times the sine of 36 okay
which is about four point seven I'm just
rounding and then for this side we can
either do the Pythagorean theorem or we
could do the cosine so we could say
cosine of 36 degrees equals adjacent
over hypotenuse that's a divided by
eight if we multiply both sides by eight
we get a by itself so that's 8 cosine 36
which is about six point five okay so
now what we're gonna do is we're going
to go back to the triangle here if this
is four point seven that's right here
four point seven this is also four point
seven so that's nine point four
and the height of the triangle we know
is six point five so if we want to find
the area we just have to do one-half the
base which is nine point four times the
height which is six point five times
five of these triangles and we've got
our area so we have let's see six point
five times nine point four times five
times 1/2
okay comes out to about a hundred fifty
two point seven five units squared and
you've got it if you want to see another
example check out the video I did right
there otherwise I'll see you in the next
video